Democratic election,
does it hold?
Doesn't it hold?
Uh,
democracy,
it is 1 word that has 1 etymology that is demos and Kratos.
Demos is the people.
Kratos is the power.
Democracy,
it is a regime in which the people exercise power.
The people decide,
it means the people vote the laws,
not Elijah of the masters.
For me,
vote and read these 2 antagonistic words,
these 2 opposite words.
When I read
I give up voting,
I read the, I
gives the name of someone who will vote for me.
So 1 democracy,
it is not a system in which we are linked,
it is 1 system in which we vote,
we vote the laws,
we don't vote for it.
But when they say, I'm going,
did you notice on Sunday when we went,
Elijah,
precisely,
we will give up voting.
It's crazy to use the same word.
Vote and read.
Uh,
I advise you to
get used to distinguishing the 2 words,
otherwise you can't think.
If so, in Switzerland,
the distinction is quite clear,
since we are voting,
we talk about vocation,
and it is in 1 college,
we vote in 1 referendum,
we decide.
Okay.
So
if democracy,
it is 1 regime in which the demos exercises the Kratos,
what should we think of democratic elections?
What is election?
The election is 1,
1 procedure by which we designate,
we represent
voluntarily.
So,
by definition,
in 1 election,
we designate.
The best,
uh.
When you choose
the one who will be your representative,
you don't choose the worst.
The election,
by construction.
All thinkers,
all the thinkers of the world before
dix-sept-cent-quatre-vingt-neuf,
all from Aristotle to Rousseau,
uh.
He knew.
And Montesquieu knew all that the election,
it doesn't even do the acting.
It's a question of definition.
The election is aristocratic,
and. And.
It is 1 procedure that allows you to choose the best,
the best,
it says Aristotle,
in Greek,
so it's 1 procedure.
A history is not bad,
uh. Well,
that's not bad in itself.
Me, uh. I.
I'm contesting the election,
me,
because the election won by elected officials,
it is 1 summary procedure,
who has the worst screws in the world.
And. And.
And.
I see,
look at the draw,
which is the only democratic procedure.
And this was also known to Aristotle,
to climb what Brousseau,
all political thinkers knew
that the only democratic procedure,
it's a draw.
And when you look at the election screws,
you put them in front of the draw.
It's like a game of chocolate.
The virtues of the draw
are the opposite of the screws of the election.
And. And.
And. Really,
uh,
democratic election,
it's 1 oxymoron,
it is 1 contradiction in the terms.
As if you said African banker,
like you're saying,
uh.
Burning snow or black light,
uh, uh,
democratic election,
it is deeply.
And yet,
we are taught that at school
since we were little.
They tell us,
election equals democracy,
democracy equals election,
repeats my little one.
So our family told us,
our teachers told us,
I told my children myself.
So it's not 1 plot with mean people that.
No, no,
we learned it ourselves
and we teach it to our children.
We learn 1 huge mistake,
we learn
so the.
Journalists say it on TV,
it is said in the books,
it is said.
Well,
everyone says so.
We end up believing it
ends up believing that the elections are democratic.
I'm just asking,
I invite you to,
you do what you want,
but I invite you to ask yourself the question,
do
when I put the name of someone who goes all out
decide for me,
because that's what election is all about,
I put the name of the chosen one
and he's the one who's going to vote,
not me.
When I do this,
I give up voting.
Am I wrong when I say this?
When I designate who will vote,
I my sovereignty,
I apply my sovereignty.
Is it democratic,
but not democratic,
It means that the demo is practiced at Kratos,
and therefore the draw,
for you,
this is the only democratic procedure that can be.
And this is the procedure that contains,
finally, which carries within it.
Hmm,
which was very important for the Athenians,
in Athens,
it was the rotation of charges.
The Athenians did not want to put it on.
The Athenians were very jealous of their sovereignty.
They wanted,
they wanted,
uh,
they had.
They had tried 1 regime in which they
decided their own destiny.
And so he was looking for
to avoid the domination of a professional,
he was looking for
avoid policy professionnalisation .
He knew that through the election,
we always designate the same ones,
because the
the conditions that have
made it possible to appoint an elected official,
are, go,
go
will continue
to allow the appointment of the same elected official.
And the same causes produce the same effects.
While with the draw,
you have the procedure for rotating loads,
the draw,
but never designated the same person twice.
So the procedure
of the draw,
it will give you the.
Political amatherism,
which is the definition of democracy.
when you accept political professionals,
you agree to democracy,
then it is possible.
If it's possible that it's better,
right,
uh,
if you distrust the people,
and if,
and if you are right,
that is,
if the people are unworthy of
to exercise power,
uh, well,
you are legitimate to think that.
It has to be aristocratic,
so it has to be the election.
But don't talk to me about democracy.
Say that you are an aristocrat,
that you are a system,
you want 1 merit system.
And that you will designate the best
and that it will be fine
better than giving power to anyone.
But if you are a,
but, uh.
Authentically Democratic,
loyally Democratic,
uh,
you have to,
finally,
you can't defend the election,
you,
you have to work on the draw,
you will see,
you go,
uh.
It's 1,
it's not 1 glare,
but if, it's,
it's,
it's really,
it's.
Are there any places in the world where,
where it's complicated ?
It's just the same in 1 life,
to discover the draw when you are a,
uh,
find out what a draw is,
while we thought we were Democrats,
and we defended democratic elections,
and then we would hold on,
we couldn't think.
And when we say to ourselves,
when we discover that
the only democratic procedure,
it's the draw,
at first, we think,
draw,
what is this,
the draw,
what is this fantasy?
And then actually,
when you work on it very quickly,
in fact,
in 1 half hour, 1 hour,
and then a few days,
but it is,
it is,
it is complicated.
You say,
but it's obvious.
But am I stupid,
am I a beast of,
of,
to have lived so much without realizing.
Are there any examples,
are there any examples,
are there any examples of places where,
where,
currently, uh.
Practice the draw, where,
in principle,
the draw,
there is 1 small book of saint-omer and his
t o m e r,
Jean Saint-Omer is one of the thinkers,
there are not many, eh,
some,
of intellectuals in France
who defend the draw,
there is nuts too.
Uh, there aren't many.
Then there's me,
uh,
there are a few,
there is also,
who works a lot on a draw,
with its citizens' agreements.
Um, but hey,
there's none,
there are not many intellectuals
in the country,
who work on the draw,
I feel.
Saint-omer is 1,
1 good,
on the question,
he wrote a little book called,
uh.
Small laboratory of democratic experimentation,
I think, something like that,
uh.
And that's quite remarkable.
This is 1 summary of
human drawing experiences.
It's enthusiasm,
here they are, the.
Obviously,
It's been a long time since humans have spotted
this procedure.
Except,
we must be uneducated,
but that's because the.
The Republican School,
uh,
which is actually 1 private line,
huh,
it's not a Republic,
right,
so it's 1 line
1,
1 thing that was uh.
Appropriate
by the 200 richest families in a long time,
eh, all along.
So we're talking about the Republic,
but you have to put quotation marks.
And the Republican School is 1 school that leads us,
we children who then become adults,
which leads us to,
to take the
submission,
obedience,
resignation.
And they don't teach us the draw,
of course,
we are not taught what it is
true democracy.
So that's why we're surprised.
But when,
when you look into the history of men,
experimentation with the draw,
the experiments of the draw,
it's exciting,
it works very well,
obviously.